Luxemburg the quiet very prosperous
country with one slow-moving problem the
population of the capital luxembourg
city doubles every working day thanks to
an influx of workers and in the morning
and evening rush hours Luxembourg City
grinds to a halt it's a familiar
difficult problem but here they've come
up with a novel solution from next year
public transport will be free for
everyone we did not yet reach the the
numbers of people taking the public
transport as we want and so came up this
idea of making public transport free and
of course we hope we hope that it will
be one of the arguments for people to
take the public transportation and this
is what's being built a new tram system
that will link trains in park-and-ride
schemes designed to make free public
transport smooth and irresistible this
isn't just a big bold initiative by the
Luxembourg government it's also got a
feel of a giant social experiment into
whether people can be made to change the
way they behave because free fares are
great for existing commuters but the
question is whether drivers can be
persuaded to swap their cars and traffic
jams for commuting on public transport
the designer is convinced he says the
system is so good inefficient everyone
will want to use it for nor towards or
drooly everyone can use this whether
you're young or old rich or poor and
everyone can say to themselves it's
better to leave the car at home when
rudeness is that what you lost on the
heart
but others more dubious taxi drivers
don't seem worried about trams stealing
their trade businessmen give ya
businessman who come here are never
going to take public transport they'll
take a taxi because they have meetings
to get to so Luxembourg's plan to remove
all fares for the government to pay for
all public transport really is a test
and it's one that plenty of bigger
nations will be watching all the big
urban areas the big economic hubs are
looking worldwide to other solutions and
in Luxembourg we have the chance as a
small country with a dynamic economy to
be little bit yeah like a lighthouse and
and really show that our possibility
other possibilities exist so that we can
find other solutions the way we move
around shapes our cities our lives our
work and our environment Luxembourg's a
very small country but this could be a
very big idea
Adam Parsons Sky News Luxembourg